on a un petit truc à vous annoncer c'est
pas une blague mentalement Juju
voilà madame madame juju
entre nous c'est pour les impôts tu sais
très bien mais non je rigole c'est pas
vrai c'est pour montrer mon amour à Juju
que j'aime fort
la caméra elle est éteinte allez petite
vidéo c'est du bon volonté
de notre vie les gars donc c'est
important de vous le dire des bisous
bonne soirée
tu sais ce que c'est le contraire d'une
péniche
un pacha
japonais quand il change d'avis
j'ai chaud j'ai changé mon Fuji d'épaule
pourquoi un gosse qui a pris les coups
de soleil il faut l'emmener à l'église
parce qu'après le gospel
oui
[Musique]
on va essayer de péter le ballon avec la
baguette magique vous m'avez tous dit
Siri tu fais le mauvais sortilège c'est
insu on va essayer ça allez c'est parti
insengo
presque deuxième essai Indian
allô
[Musique]